hey guys how's it going so with Jenna's
birthday know I'm getting older her we
did this really fun video in Easter
where she was my arms oh no it didn't go
well
it is Oh No here's something else that
didn't go very well I went to a tool
concert and I asked for a small city she
gave me large so you put your arms in
there to hug her this way wait no other
way like you look I'm putting it on yes
and then I is it's not even close okay
wait wait do I not go in the hole
wait you're in your own eye I'm in the
hole ah uncomfortably close oh my god
here okay is that good
well my mic is in your back okay so
maybe I'll just move this I don't
understand it still I know I'm here
living it and I still don't understand
it
fix up here we go look I'm gonna put
this over your but there's no way that's
gonna fit my boy okay okay alright yeah
what can you can you fix my hair Jen
what do you want to do you know like
part it like nice oh that's nice
okay wait my hair can you okay you arms
doesn't mean my mobility is strengthened
okay fix my right hair other sides like
I need like pull away from my face away
from ya okay we're to like knit close by
my eye okay okay
wait one more on that side that's nice
you just sweaty show me your arms oh
those are my arms okay so today we're
gonna make some cupcakes and I'm super
excited because I've got a lot of really
good things here for you three so
filming could you really sleeves up what
you got okay so we're gonna start with
pink all right I don't know I'll just ya
know you don't have well you're taller
than me okay okay you want a hat
do I have I have where's your hat I
gotta get a hat four legs oh stop it so
high I'm done what stupid time to
decorate okay let's pick up a cupcake
okay I've got my cupcake right here and
now I'm gonna get some icing I prefer to
get the pink icing that looks to be the
vanilla so I'm gonna go over just a
little bit no more colors but no what no
it's that one now that I've got my pink
icing this a la sprinkles on the top and
I'm gonna be very very careful
no I get it sprinkled everywhere so I
need to get a spatula it's funny because
I think there's one yep oh boy
I've got a big one really roll my
sleeves up you know okay white house fix
hola wait I've got an alien arm my god
my cupcake here and what I would like to
do is I'm going to just flip my spatula
over the other way and I'm gonna just
gently slide the cupcake on to the ice
oh that looks very good it's very very
nice Oh looks like I've got a little bit
penis my favorite color
when I like working with I think I love
using pink
I'm kind of hard of seeing so okay now
that I've got at least one cupcake ice
I'm gonna start doing some decorating
let's see what else I can see I'm just
gonna pick up some sprinkles these are
my favorites they're silver and they're
very ear doesn't this is homemade and
fresh but it's store-bought okay now
that I've got my sprinkles I'm gonna try
to sprinkle it on okay now I'm gonna
know that's not my a cupcake that's my
cupcake it's weird because when I look
down I see cupcakes but you don't okay
that looks nice
okay I'm really thirsty can I have my
drink no I'm good no that's all my
drinking okay just
I'm crying I'm crying so much okay um
next up I'd like to ice the cake I'm
honestly when I laugh like I cry like
look can you see the tears on my face
because I am a hot mess is there a voice
in my head said I'm hearing way I'm
having a hard time opening this one all
right here we go we're gonna just open
this up and what I love so much about
these is we've got rid of tips and you
can just shove a tip on and then shut
the tip on shove the tip on the shove it
the tip on and then you just pull it off
shake it up I guess and then and then
you do it you don't want to go too far
away from your cupcake because if you do
I guess no so silly me this is silly
this is silly cooking with Justine and
her arms okay we're gonna just do a
little bit of decorating on this one
this is a brand new cupcake it's real
fresh
I love making cupcakes for Dale's
birthday okay that's that's something
that happened so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna try that again that's not as
good as the other one so I'm gonna just
decorate this real nice cuz Jenna's
favorite color is I'm not actually sure
what Jenna's favorite color is but I
seem to be doing a very good job on this
one hey Jenna what's your favorite color
cuz I feel like really blue now I've got
one blue cupcake made for Jenna I'm
gonna see what else I've got over here
jenna loves Hershey bars so I'm gonna
try to find a Hershey bar and I
I'm gonna try to find a Hershey bar okay
[Music]
okay oh I'm so sorry I stepped on your
little foot god I'm sweating I'm
comfortable and comforta name one
I hear Jenna only ones two cupcakes
decorated okay we're gonna make a very
special cupcake this for the last one
cuz I'm crying and Jenna's crotch is
warm and I'm feeling super uncomfortable
so where's that would open up this
Hershey's bar it's a very big bar I
don't roll my sleeves up I'm sweating
I'm sweating up a storm that's gonna
taste like okay wait alien arm so I'm
gonna break this snap or a third
whatever and now we're gonna what am I
gonna do I'm not sure actually I'm gonna
grab a cupcake is what I'm gonna do oh
here it is
looking good gosh I love I single-piece
I just want to see what I'm doing I like
to really get up loose it personal looks
like it was my subjects now we're gonna
put the candles in
[Music]
I seem to be having them it's almost
like my hands are not communicating with
my head okay I'm gonna put that in that
looks good
wow I can see it because it's very close
to my face yeah how old's Jenna turning
this year one now I need something to
like this one tweeted and said I guess
I'm gonna knock that one out in a while
okay cool so now I'm gonna like this
can't oh geez oh my god no I'm just
gonna move down like that oh my god
happy birthday get out of here I can't I
[Music]
can't touch you because I thought things
on my hand
hello okay thank you guys believe that
wasn't one person in there we really
sold it happy birthday Jenna I'm getting
too old for this
you see oh god I've got so much crap in
my hair what do I do now
I'm sweating actually disgusting
[Music]